CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe is with
us now from Washington he's a
congressional correspondent for the
Washington Post ed good morning and
let's start with that speech listen this
was his eighth campaign style rally
since he became president back in
January and he lasted 76 minutes the
first 20 plus minutes was bashing the
press and he was very selective in what
he remembered in what he had shared on
Saturday so what do you make of the
content and the tone you know I think if
folks tuned in and thought they were
watching a repeat from 2015 or 2016 they
could be forgiven for that because there
was a lot of what we saw from the
presidential candidate Donald Trump last
night play out yet again in a city that
he's been to before and in a state that
clearly has supporters that love him
dearly but look beyond the media bashing
beyond the revisionist history of what
he said in the wake of the
Charlottesville violence there was some
real news in there I think most
especially the threat of shutting down
the federal government should Congress
not provide the money he wants to start
expanding and building out the border
wall along the border with Mexico that
is a expected to be a real flashpoint
when Congress comes back to town just
after Labor Day and has only just a few
days to figure out how to keep the
government open and set spending levels
going forward what do you and into that
so far I think a lot of jaws dropped at
that remark absolutely and look there
are Democrats don't want to see that
money set aside for a new border wall
there are a lot of Republicans who are
wary of doing it as well he spoke in a
state last night where a majority of
Arizonans don't think there needs to be
a border wall ditto in Texas and most of
California already has one or at least
the parts that need it so he wants to
fulfill a signature campaign pledge he
expects Congress to delivered for him
we'll see whether or not that happens
and it raises the prospects for yet
another government shutdown beginning
September 30th October first it has only
happened just a handful of times in the
last century that the Republican Party
has controlled the presidency in both
houses of Congress you have wall street
you have business leaders all hoping
that this president this Congress will
get something done what does it mean
that the president is essentially
committing fratricide screaming
obscenities at the Senate Majority
Leader and then bashing too
Republican senators in their own home
state it means it's going to be very
difficult for the Republican Party to
demonstrate that they can run Washington
and the federal government especially as
they face these big deadlines and these
big items on their to-do list you know
the got to start talking about tax
reform their supporters expect them to
do that they want to do it they've got
to keep the government open after
September they've got to raise the debt
limit by October first as well when the
president's running around criticizing
Republicans swearing at them on the
telephone and generally raising concerns
about whether they have America's best
interest in mind it's gonna be very hard
for the White House to work but and what
are you learning from your own reporting
I mean we heard the Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan indicate just this week that
it's gonna be much easier to get tax
reform done are they close on that at
all no no they're not
that we don't know that they have a real
big plan ready to go and even if they do
it's gonna take several more months
before they can really get that ball
rolling ed O'Keefe always good to hear
your wisdom thanks for joining us this
morning I'm a good guy